يواجه دونالد ترامب مادتين من
المساءلة أو تهمتين إساءة استخدام
السلطة وعرقلة عمل الكونجرس يوم
الأربعاء ، سيصوت مجلس النواب
ليقرر ما إذا كان سيوجه
هذه التهم رسميًا ولم يعد هناك
أي تشويق بشأن
حصول الديمقراطيين على أغلبية في مجلس النواب و  من
المتوقع أن يوافقوا على مواد
الإقالة في تلك المرحلة السيد.
ومع ذلك ، سيُعتبر ترامب رسميًا موضع عزل ، وغالبًا ما يكون هذا هو
الجزء الذي يُساء فهمه ، حيث سيبقى في
منصبه في انتظار المحاكمة التي
ستُعقد في مجلس الشيوخ على الأرجح الشهر المقبل
، وستقرر هذه المحاكمة في النهاية ما
إذا كان السيد.  يظل ترامب رئيسًا أو
لا
يظل مجلس الشيوخ تحت سيطرة
السيد.  حلفاء ترامب الجمهوريون ، كل
ما أفعله
خلال هذا الأمر ، أقوم بالتنسيق مع
مستشار البيت الأبيض ، لن يكون هناك
فرق بين موقف الرئيس
وموقفنا ، ولا توجد
فرصة لإقالة الرئيس
من منصبه ، إليكم ما نعرفه عن
محاكمة مجلس الشيوخ للرئيس الأمريكي
يترأس قاضي المحكمة العليا هذا الشيء
الذي يختاره المشرعون من قبل مجلس
النواب لعرض القضية على أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
الذين يعملون هنا بشكل أساسي كمحلفين
ثم يصوت السناتور على ما إذا كان يجب
عزل الرئيس ، فهذا عائق مرتفع
للغاية للقاء تحتاج إلى اثنين  - الأغلبية الثالثة
لإدانة أن 67
عضوًا في مجلس الشيوخ وفي هذا المناخ السياسي ،
هناك أشياء غير مرجحة للغاية
بشأن المحاكمة التي لا نعرف الآن
ما إذا كان الرئيس سيظهر بالفعل
إلى متى قد تستمر المحاكمة وما هي
الأدلة التي يمكن أن تكون.  تم تقديمه ومن إذا كان
سيسمح لأي شخص بالإدلاء بشهادته ، فإن
الجمهوريين يميلون إلى إجراء محاكمة سريعة
وقد يتخطون
شهادة الشهود البديلة  معًا ، لا أريد
استدعاء أي شخص ، هذا الشيء سيأتي إلى
مجلس الشيوخ وسيموت بسرعة
وسأفعل كل ما بوسعي لجعله يموت
سريعًا بشكل جيد لأنه
قد يرغب الديمقراطيون في جلب شهود رئيسيين
منهم
رئيس الأركان بالإنابة للرئيس ميك مولفاني ومحاكمة
مستشاره السابق للأمن القومي جون
بولتون
لديهم شهود. هذا ما تدور
حوله جميع المحاكمات حول هؤلاء الأشخاص يعرفون أكثر من
أي شخص آخر الحقائق لا يوجد
سبب على أرض الله الخضراء
لعدم استدعائهم والإدلاء بشهادتهم  ما
لم تكن خائفًا مما قد يقولوه ،
إذا اتخذت خطوة كبيرة إلى الوراء ، فما الذي
يعلمنا إياه اكتساح التاريخ هذا ، هل يتضمن
أي دروس جيدًا نوعًا ما من ثلاثة
رؤساء قبل أن يواجه ترامب
محاكمة عزل اثنين تم عزلهما من قبل
المنزل أندرو جونسون في  في القرن التاسع
عشر وبيل كلينتون في التسعينيات ،
تمت تبرئة كليهما من قبل مجلس الشيوخ
واحتفظوا بوظائفهم ، حيث
استقال ريتشارد نيكسون قبل انتهاء إجراءاته ،
لكن الثلاثة  شهد الرؤساء السابقون
الذين واجهوا إجراءات عزل
أحزابهم خسارة البيت الأبيض في
الانتخابات التالية